Her low freak bitches.
I've,
I've taught that story is crazy.
I was telling a friend of mine about it,
the,
uh,
the story of you,
you were in Alberta and you shot an elk
and these wolves circled the elk.
How many,
how many?
Well,
at first there was just the one,
the one came in and you know,
the one came in on us and I,
and I,
and that's one I do want to say off the
beginning.
One thing that I always do as a hunter
is I always buy a Predator tag if it's
available,
if I know that I can get,
uh,
that I can buy a tag for coyotes or
wolves,
I always have one in my pocket.
Because you do see,
you know,
they're out there and they're out there
way more now and this,
and this is an exact reason why he got
to do it because literally we had an elk
down and next thing you know we're out
there kind of,
you know,
getting it ready to like,
to cut it up and stuff and get it out of
there and all sudden this big wolf comes
through,
you know,
it comes in and I had spotted it and we
weren't really being noisy.
So I ended up shooting that wolf and it
kind of went off.
And you know,
with a bow there's no noise.
So what we didn't realize was there was
a pack there and that that was actually,
it was an Alpha female is because of the
size of it.
I mean,
you saw the size of it is a big as me
and it actually went off and then we
kind of thought,
wow,
it's freaking freaky.
We'll then about 20 minutes later all
sudden we see another one and we see
another one and we're kinda like,
holy crap.
So we start moving into this draw and
one of them was like making like a
noise,
almost like it was injured or something.
And I was like whimpering.
So we're like,
what is the deal?
So we,
we were on high ground with the elk and
then we started moving down into this
ravine because we saw the wolves down in
there.
And next thing you know,
we get down in there and I start looking
around and there's like hair on the
trees.
There's like,
I mean it looked like that movie into
the gray,
that's exactly what it looked like.
Liam Neeson,
there was like fricking Harry turds
everywhere.
It was just,
there was like beds,
there was hair rubbed on the trees.
And I started looking around and there's
like holes dug in and I'm like,
I literally look at my two buddies that
were there with me and I said,
right.
And they're fricking den like,
you know,
and I think we had that elk was not too
far,
you know,
our elk wasn't too far.
You shot an elk that they probably
thought of as theirs.
Oh,
they definitely thought of it was
theirs.
Yeah,
they,
they definitely thought that was theirs.
So then once we're down there all sudden
we hear this,
how were like down there,
we hear this how,
and it was definitely an Alpha because
an Alphas,
the how,
it literally turns your blood instantly
if you're right in on a true wolf howl.
It's,
I mean it's like,
so freaking low and deep and it's just
like chills your blood.
Well,
yeah.
Then I realized,
I'm like,
we're in their fricking Dan and you
know,
I'm kind of looking down.
I'm like,
okay,
well shot an elk.
Then I shot that.
I've got two arrows left.
So,
and you know,
both my guides kind of had,
you know,
once we said,
oh,
there's wolves,
they like grabbed a gun and we kind of
went down in there to see what was up.
Well now this happens.
A next thing after that Alpha sounded
off,
it was like,
Ooh,
Ooh.
And I mean 12,
I think it was 12 sounded off all the
way around us.
We're in,
uh,
we're,
we're literally down.
Anyone who's been in Alberta,
you know that the farm land is level and
then it falls into the river system.
So we're literally,
they have the high ground,
there's a dozen wolves and we're in the
middle and we're like,
what the crap.
So I just,
I'm like,
get you back to a tree so we can all
spin around and we're sitting there and
next thing you know here comes to dogs
on a full blown,
I'm talking like full blown like this,
like front running coming.
And I mean it turned into chaos.
There was like bullets flying.
I mean there's fricking arrows skipping
off junk.
And we ended up shooting both of those
wolves dead and there's a few gunfires
going off while I'm down to like one
Arrow left and I told the guy said how
many bullets you got?
And he goes,
well I didn't,
I,
you know,
I just grabbed the gun to couple bullets
like I didn't know were this was all
going down,
so it can't,
we're kind of like,
we need to get outta here.
So we started backing up and next thing
you know they,
the Alpha sounded off again and they all
reported this time there's only two or
two less.
So next thing I know I'm like kind of,
we're trying to back out.
So when you say that,
wait a minute,
hold on a second.
You say they reported there's,
so there's,
they know that two were dead.
Yeah,
all of them are Howlin.
I'm certain that the first,
how was the Alpha male?
Pretty much saying is everyone in
position because then they all like,
yes,
yes.
All the way around.
Then all of a sudden the two come,
all hell breaks loose.
Then we're like the alpha sounds again,
but he's in a different location.
He was actually to my left like right
here and it really close and I mean it's
thick in there.
You've been there,
you know how thick it gets.
So then they sound awful.
Now this time there's two less.
So I'm kind of looking,
cause I know this wolf that sounded was,
and I know it's the Alpha,
so I like grabbed my bow and I start
kinda creeping over there.
And as soon as I get to where I can see,
he's like fricking standing right there.
And how far were 30 yards,
which actually both can cover.
Jamie,
pull up that picture from,
I'm Joe's instagram.
Like it was about a week ago.
You found those pictures of those
wolves?
Yeah.
I forget who the photographer was.
There's got some amazing photographs or
yeah,
it was,
it was like not the most recent one on
that was on that dead Moose,
but it was from national geographic.
That was actually a bison.
Those from yesterday.
That's right.
Yesterday or the day before.
Look at that right there.
That is exactly the face that I saw in
the,
but he was head on.
He wasn't broad side,
but that face where he was literally
looking at me like that and I mean
you're in a fight or flight like I'm in
totally in a fight or flight.
I had one arrow left on my string.
I fricking grabbed my bow.
I literally,
I like,
I just,
I kind of looked at him.
I knew at that moment it was like he was
coming.
Yeah.
That's it's like fricking Deja Vu,
right?
The twitter,
the instagram page,
Jamie,
to go back up a little bit is c j m
underscore photography and if you go to
that guy's instagram page,
he's got an amazing photographs just,
and he's out there with them.
There was another one that I had and
it's just right before that Jamie,
the,
before that wolf picture,
there was another wolf picture.
That one.
Look at that one man,
he's got snow all over his face and his
teeth are bare.
That's a cool,
yeah,
that's a cool picture.
Like to me that's pretty cool.
Wools are amazing.
They're amazing.
And the one thing people underestimate
about hunters is our respect for
animals.
I freaking,
I totally respect him.
I love him.
But I can tell you that other picture
right there when you have that looking
at you in the face,
I mean,
I knew it was like fricking do or die
and I,
I literally looked at that thing and I
said out loud,
I said,
I'm going to shoot you in theF and face
because you don't swear.
Yeah,
sorry.
It's cute.
And my boy might listen.
I remember I drew back.
Oh.
Like I literally drew back and I
anchored and that came into my peep.
And as soon means for people don't know,
there's like a little circle that you
look at through the string line lining
up with your site.
So I was literally lining up the shot,
lining up the shot,
and as soon as I kind of brought my shot
down to where that wolf was,
there was nothing there.
He bolted.
No,
I think he just like,
yeah,
like Ninja ad.
If they're that wise and that big and
that old,
they've got to know what smarter.
It had to have known that you killed the
elk and they had to have known that you
killed those other two wolves that
chased you went after the ALC.
I think he came in to to think,
okay,
we've see you called the fight.
We responded.
Now he's like sizing up.
Okay,
I've lost.
Here's what I've lost.
I want to know what I'm going against.
He kind of came in and he fricking
looked at us all and then that was it.
Good thing they can't count for you.
Who you only had two hours.
Yeah,
two hours and two bullets.
Bullets the guy up.
It was bone chilling.
And I mean,
I have,
you and I both have friends that are you
grizzlies cats.
I mean,
cats are notorious for stalking hunters
too.
Cause I mean,
they are the ultimate hunter.
Um,
but grizzlies and wolves,
I mean,
there you have to be on guard that,
you know,
there's places now we're,
grizzlies are strongly becoming such a
problem when it comes to,
you know,
they have to be controlled.
They're just starting to get to be too
many for,
especially for the food source.